Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Pose estimation is an interesting area of
research where we typically have a few images
or video footage of humans, and we try to
automatically extract the pose this person
was taking.
In short, the input is mostly a 2D image,
and the output is typically a skeleton of
the person.
Applications of pose estimation include automatic
creation of assets for computer games and
digital media, analyzing and coaching the
techniques of athletes, or helping computers
understand what they see for the betterment
of robotics and machine learning techniques.
And this is just a taste, the list was by
no means exhaustive.
Beyond the obvious challenge of trying to
reconstruct 3D information from a simple 2D
image, this problem is fraught with difficulties
as one has to be able to overcome the ambiguity
of lighting, occlusions, and clothing covering
the body.
A tough problem, no question about that.
An ideal technique would do this automatically
without any user intervention, which sounds
like wishful thinking.
Or does it?
In this paper, a previously proposed convolutional
neural network is used to predict the position
of the individual joints, and curiously, it
turns out that we can create a faithful representation
of the 3D human body from that by means of
optimization.
We have had a previous episode on mathematical
optimization, you know the drill, the link
is available in the video description box.
What is remarkable here is that not only the
pose, but the body type is also inferred,
therefore the output of the process is not
just a skeleton, but full 3D geometry.
It is coarse geometry, so don't expect a ton
of details, but it's 3D geometry, more than
what most other competing techniques can offer.
To ease the computational burden of this problem,
in this optimization formulation, healthy
constraints are assumed that apply to the
human body, such as avoiding unnatural knee
and elbow bends, and self-intersections.
If we use these constraints, the space in
which we have to look for possible solutions
shrinks considerably.
The results show that this algorithm outperforms
several other state of the art techniques
by a significant margin.
It is an auspicious opportunity to preserve
and recreate a lot of historic events in digital
form, maybe even use them in computer games,
and I am sure that artists will make great
use of such techniques.
Really well done, the paper is extremely well
written, the mathematics and the optimization
formulations are beautiful, it was such a
joy to read.
Regarding the future, I am pretty sure we're
soon going to see some pose and skeleton transfer
applications via machine learning.
The input would be a real-world video with
a person doing something, and we could essentially
edit the video and bend these characters to
our will.
There are some exploratory works in this area
already, the Disney guys for instance are
doing quite well.
There will be lots of fun to be had indeed!
Also, make sure to check out the YouTube channel
of Welch Labs, who has a great introductory
series for neural networks, which is in my
opinion, second to none.
He also has a new series called "Learning
to see", where he codes up a machine learning
technique for a computer vision application.
It is about counting the number of fingers
on an image.
Really cool, right?
The quality of these videos is through the
roof, the link for both of these series are
available in the description box, make sure
to check them out!
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!